[Música]
temos claro engenharia mecânica
naturalmente que tem um grande interesse
por inovação tecnológica e como mofo no
meu trabalho é como é que a tecnologia
pode ter um impacto no mundo como é que
a tecnologia no jóia intense ar a nossa
capacidade de resolver problemas
atualmente sou aluna de doutoramento em
engenharia mecânica no instituto
superior técnico onde faz uma
investigação sobre a tensão inteligente
fogos florestais
hoje vamos falar um pouco da idéia da
minha tese
mas antes vou voltar um pouco atrás para
percebermos como é que chegamos aqui em
conta instante e para onde queremos ir
como vamos ligar as coisas e como fazer
hoje eu mexer nos anos 90 eu sei que não
foi há muito tempo mas ainda conheci o
mundo antes dar vos móvel que tem
acontecido nas últimas décadas e tem a
perspectiva comum era muito diferente ea
forma como interagimos mudou muito
especialmente o ritmo que interagimos
nos anos 90 havia uma das empresas
responsável pela rápida massificação dos
telemóveis têm este mantra poderosíssimo
que era a missão de ligar as pessoas
rapidamente nos convenceram andar com
onde jogou no bolso e bateria da prova e
mesmo tempo não havia câmeras apenas em
alguns jogos uma e cada mensagem escrita
com uma síntese biográfica para não
tropeçar gente se refere mas foram
precisos apenas 70 anos para os
telemóveis serem completamente
inventados e hoje fazemos coisas com o
telemóvel que eles achavam que queira
inimagináveis hoje tarifárias tem quase
todos comunicações limitadas e muito
graças à internet estamos todos
permanentemente ligados nesta rede
ganhou uma magnitude gum tática e foram
precisos muito poucos anos para se
cumprir esta missão do ligar as pessoas
e poucos
são eles o tecnológico estão tendo um
crescimento tão rápido é em não num
curso espaço tempo e agora o que se
segue
sexy ligar as coisas este conceito é
muito conhecido como a internet das
coisas e hoje em dia as mais variadas
indústrias trabalhos neste desafio de
ligar tudo o resto
isso vai desde o serviço temos em nossa
casa que nos permitem controlar a
televisão com telemóvel ou imprimir
documentos na impressora através da rede
sem fio ou a ao setor industrial onde se
atravessa atualmente uma quarta
resolução industrial mas vamos ligar as
coisas e em que é que isto não vai
ajudar
bem isto vai nos trazer outros problemas
como a privacidade da proteção de dados
da silva à segurança problemas com cuja
hoje em dia nos confrontamos ainda que
nem sempre três anos com o consciente
quando ligar estudo esta tecnologia todo
em que estamos nos ajuda sendo
engenheira eu acho que nos vai dar
ferramentas para enfrentarmos alguns dos
maiores desafios da minha geração como é
o caso das alterações climáticas e isso
traz nos a a pergunta que será hoje
trouxe aqui partilhar convosco de
covardes para onde eu vou
e em começar um pouco atrás há um ano
atrás
no último ano euros no ano passado
estava no último ano do meu curso e
tinha de escolher um tema até se na
altura pareceu este projecto inovador
que multiplicou em 3
o objetivo era criar um sistema que
permite desfazer a atenção do foco de
incêndio de forma automática através de
sensores de imagem
o projeto para ser um local extremamente
aliciante porque eu juntava uma área de
investigação
era das minhas preferidas do curso que
era sistemas inteligentes e era aplicado
uma problemática real que era uma coisa
que durante o meu curso
a maior parte dos trabalhos eram o
computacionais ou dissimulação e que
tenha uma forte componente experimental
teve oportunidade neste tempo durante o
projeto fire campo 2 que era dedicado à
segurança contra incêndios em parques de
campismo e de caravanismo e realizei a
minha tese de mestrado em colaboração
com a associação para o desenvolvimento
da aerodinâmica industrial onde tive a
oportunidade de realizar ensaios no
centro de estudos sobre incêndios
florestais
aí durante vários meses a estudar vários
tipos de sensores para percebermos como
é que íamos usar a tecnologia atual
para criar esse sistema não foi assim
tão trivial e tivemos de ultrapassar
várias dificuldades mas no final eu
gosto que ter bons resultados e concluí
até em outubro no entanto o último ano
mudou muito a nossa consciência sobre
esta questão dos focos e portugal é um
país onde o nível de perigosidade de
incêndio é muito grande
uma grande parte do território e
infelizmente no ano passado o veículo as
condições que se verificaram uma grande
parte destas há três sofreram um enorme
impacto como os grandes incêndios que
ocorreram na zona centro
isto motivou um pouco uma maior atenção
para estampar esta questão da detenção a
temporada dos focos numa fase inicial
pois se os incêndios foram interpretados
ainda no seu início é muito mais fácil
combater os incêndios
isto vamos continuar a fazer
investigação mesmo depois de acabado o
curso e enquanto em algumas entrevistas
de emprego
na altura e apesar de existirem muitas
oportunidades na minha área
é nenhuma me importava particularmente o
em 3 e foi em mais ou menos abril que eu
fui a uma entrevista que era em uma
empresa de sonho para qualquer pessoa do
meu curso e nem aí eu estava convencido
que ia largar este projecto em que
estava a trabalhar para ir por essa
empresa foi que eu percebi que aquilo
não era o meu sonho e que já estava a
trabalhar naquilo que realmente quer
fazer
foi então candidato tenham concurso das
nações unidas que o ian mcshane ser é um
jovem de campeões da terra que é um
concurso que procura apoiar jovens com
idéias vanguardistas que tem um
potencial impacto bom impacto ambiental
concorreram jovens de todo mundo com
idéias e soluções para o desenvolvimento
sustentável e para a proteção do meio
ambiente e depois foram selecionados 35
finalistas à escala global das várias
regiões do mundo e eu tive o privilégio
de ter a minha velha esquerda com uma
das cinco finalistas da europa
a idéia que eu propus consiste numa em
criar uma rede de sensores estáticos e
sensores a bordo plataformas móveis como
android ou balões da altitude que
permite fazer a monitorização do meio
ambiente com o objetivo de detectar os
focos de incêndio ainda numa fase
inicial é que ligarmos as coisas a gente
pode ajudar
imaginem que temos uma rede de sensores
espalhados numa zona rural e quando
ocorre um aumento de temperatura ou o
fun estendido por sensores e através de
algoritmos inteligentes conseguem
detetar o início de um furto
assim transmitir localmente o que se
passa no meio ambiente e com esta
observação e em função dela conseguimos
controlar esta rede de plataformas
móveis que se adapta e permite atender
as zonas de oferecem maior risco
os sistemas centralizados ainda não
existem atualmente
mas quando forem implementados podem ser
uma grande mais valia para as
autoridades pois permitem obter
informação atualizada em tempo real e
permitem servir para o apoio à decisão
pois tem mais informação usou
profissionais podem fazer uma melhor
alocação dos recursos disponíveis tendo
em conta a salvaguarda da vida humana
quer das populações quer das forças dos
profissionais que estão na linha de
combate
esse é o trabalho que estou a
desenvolver no âmbito e até do
tratamento
e apesar de ainda estar no início
espero poder contribuir para que este
tipo de sistema se torne uma realidade
afinal se o mundo mudou tanto em tão
pouco tempo não começarmos agora e por
que não criar esses temas
aqui em portugal é incluso sofremos este
flagelo dos incêndios
gabriela
[Aplausos]